[Music]  seems no one really understands how  obamacare works so  president obama gave it one last try in  a big speech in maryland tried to clear  up all the confusion take a look  so i want to take uh a little bit of  time today to speak with you  about the reforms that we are making to  our health care system  there's been a lot of confusion  but let me just try to explain what's in  the law  i know that uh uninsured americans  that  and here's  what what what is it that everybody what  is it that  i don't know i know what i'm telling you  no no no  look  i i want to be honest  i i have never felt so scared or  helpless in all of my life and a lot of  it is just  uh  you